apple is one of the largest tech
companies in the world today there are
few people on earth who haven't heard of
their products in this day and age it
already has a massive influence on the
world the apple of the future might have
even more influence the apple of the
future would not just be a tech company
but a lifestyle company already it has
products that influence so many spheres
of our lives from work watching tv
working out and even healthcare but it
has far greater visions for the future
join us as we explore the apple of the
future we will look at future products
their influence and overall what apple
wants for the future of humanity apple
iphone of the future let's just look at
how far apple iphone has come in the
last decade we see exceptional growth
and technology and capability the iphone
went from a simple mobile device with a
touch screen and easy access to the
internet to a mobile powerhouse that can
work with things like mobile x-ray
devices the evolution in just the last
decade is so substantial that it is
tough to predict the future of the
iphone 10 years from now let alone 30
years from now maybe the apple iphones
of 2050 are just as powerful or even
more powerful as a desktop computer
these days this is something not outside
the realm of possibilities computers
have become thousands of times faster in
just a few decades combining this with
developing technology like holograms you
can have a device that is directly out
of star wars movies imagine carrying a
smartphone so powerful that you can sit
down anywhere and do really intensive
renderings or simulations and such
possibilities are today seemed more
likely than they would 10 years ago and
this is all speculation smartphones may
be redundant in the near future and we
have moved to more sophisticated methods
of communication social interaction and
entertainment apple's future in ar and
vr talking about more sophisticated
methods of social interaction and
entertainment apple has been in the news
for making moves in the virtual reality
and augmented reality sectors apple is
now offering a new set of tools in the
coming mac os sierra software that will
let developers connect vr headsets and
create 3d and vr content apple is doing
this to make sure that apple's most
dedicated class of users these are
creators artists and other professionals
have the tools it needs to create the
content of the future and this is just
the beginning for apple in the vr space
last year in may apple acquired a
company called nextvr so we may see
apple vr devices in the near future
these vr devices won't just be for
entertainment and creative purposes
these devices could help surgeons
perform complicated surgeries similarly
engineers would use apple's devices to
virtually go inside big machines to look
for cracks and other indications of
failure the possibilities are endless
according to a bloomberg report apple
plans to launch its first ar device soon
the apple glass apple glass aims to
bridge the gap between the real world
and the digital one and apple wants to
integrate the apple glass into our lives
like they integrated apple iphones into
our lives and these technologies are
just starting out right now just imagine
how these technologies evolve and impact
our lives 20 30 years from now but ar
and vr aren't just where apple will stop
in fact apple may have even grander
plans for its future products brainwaves
controlled devices back in 2010 there
was a pretty exciting gizmo on the
market that worked with apple's iphone
called x-wave it was basically a device
that allowed you to control functions on
your iphone just using your brain it
consisted of a headset that the user
would wear and the headset would then
connect to your iphone via the x-wave
application the x-wave headset had a few
sensors that pressed against the
forehead of the user the free x-wave
application would then show your brain's
waves graphically on the iphone screen
as you focus your mind on a task the
graphics change a ball may move higher
for instance or your state of relaxation
may be indicated by changes in a
pulsating color which moves towards blue
as you become more relaxed the headset
only cost a hundred dollars and it would
connect to your iphone via the headset
jack but it was a pretty mesmerizing
experience that your brain activity
could not only be read but also
differentiated based on your mood and
this technology was possible just 11
years ago just imagine what we could
achieve 10 years from now 20 years from
now people are already working on making
brain computer interfaces that will
allow us to control our devices using
thought apple is a technology leader and
i can't imagine that apple would not
heavily invest in this technology to
bring their own line of apple devices
that are controlled via thought such an
innovation would be similar in scale to
that of smartphones it would totally
revolutionize how humans interact with
technology a brain controlled apple
device for your daily task would be so
convenient just imagine walking down the
sidewalk and you think about texting
someone and that text is already sent
from the device in your pocket without
you touching it we are almost near that
technology with things like bluetooth
headphones and voice assistants like
siri but a brain control device could
totally change how we interact with
technology apple could already be
working on such a technology and we
might not even know ambient computing
apple has also recently pitched their
new home assistant device the apple
homepod this is apple's way of getting
inside your home and the ambient
computing market similar to amazon's
echo device by establishing a permanent
presence inside your home apple is
planning to expand its ecosystem in the
future apple will use this to expand to
an overall iot house that works on
apple's infrastructure imagine you come
to your home and your apple car is
connected to your apple home device it
automatically opens the garage door for
you then when you enter the house the
lights are already on and the heating or
cooling has been turned on automatically
to prepare for your arrival these
technologies are part of tim cook's plan
for apple for the next 10 years but just
imagine what these technologies could
look like 30 years from now your apple
watch realizes you have an important
meeting tomorrow it automatically
prepares a good suit from your wardrobe
using apple's humanoid robots the
possibilities are endless if we look
that far ahead apple carbon neutral
apple has been very much focused on
sustainability and reducing its carbon
print for a long time now when apple
announced its new campus building back
in 2015 it promised that it would be
based on green energy and sustainability
and they stuck with that promise when
apple park opened in 2017. it had half
the energy usage of a typical office
building it used renewable energy
resources to offset its energy demands
staying true to its sustainability goals
apple has pledged that it will be
entirely carbon neutral by 2030 by
entire they actually mean everything
this means everything they make and use
will be made in a 100 carbon neutral way
even their supply chains will be
ultimately carbon neutral by 2030. in a
press release apple ceo tim cook
reaffirmed why apple is setting these
aggressive goals for itself businesses
have a profound opportunity to help
build a more sustainable future one born
from our common concern for the planet
we share climate action can be the
foundation for a new era of innovative
potential job creation and durable
economic growth with our commitment to
carbon neutrality we hope to be a ripple
in the pond that creates a much larger
change apple's commitment to a
sustainable future might also encourage
other businesses and tech companies to
follow suit the apple of the future just
doesn't want to make products that
positively impact people's lives they
want to create products that impact the
earth and the biosphere positively as
well because no matter how you put it
the impending climate change disaster
would be bad for business and it is
refreshing to see that apple is paving
the way for future companies to also
hold themselves to higher levels of
social responsibility a change like this
would also mean that apple will have to
rethink and recreate the entire process
this will foster a new age of innovation
and technology as not only apple makes
new and better products but these
products are also less harmful to the
environment apple of the future will be
on the cutting edge of new technologies
like it is today but not only that the
apple of 2050 might even be doing things
that we might not fully comprehend today
products that work on the brain to
computer interfaces that don't involve
another form of input apple has already
shown that they make robust enough
products that can be sent into space but
most importantly apple has a very
optimistic view of its future and the
future of humanity a future where
sustainability is a core value where
products and services don't harmfully
affect life on earth as we know it this
is the apple of the future we might see
in 2050